uh now our next guest spent 650 days in
one of Asia's most notorious prisons the
Australian Economist Sean Turnell was in
Myanmar advising the democratically
elected leader when she was overthrown
by a military coup in February of last
year he has written about his experience
which included rats scorpions and
multiple baths of covid he's now back on
the home soil after being released from
prison two weeks ago he joins us now
from Sydney hello to you good morning
good afternoon where you are how are you
feeling
I'm feeling great now okay I wasn't
feeling good before when I was there in
Myanmar in the cell with all those
animals that you mentioned uh but I'm
certainly good now back in back in
Sydney Australia tell us what happened
uh well I was arrested back in February
2021 a couple of days after the coup in
which uh Ong song tsuchi was taking into
custody I was taken into custody five
days later uh put in prison put on a
sham trial uh and ultimately sentenced
for three years uh and then released uh
two weeks ago today yeah but not today a
little bit a little bit more on that
um and um yeah so just so pleased to be
home
what were the conditions like talk to us
about the conditions you were kept in
other conditions were terrible
um they were the conditions in which uh
normal Burmese people can expect uh I
think when I was first arrested I
expected something a little bit
different that didn't turn out to be the
case and I was treated more or less the
same as everyone else or the other
prisoners and the insects and so on that
you described would come into the cell
every day uh it was exceedingly hot of
course uh the food was terrible and I
got sick multiple times and I got
covered four times while I was there so
it was not a good experience at all
um there were various times when I had
nothing to read and nothing to sort of
stimulate my mind so I had to do a lot
of pacing of cells and things like that
but yeah eventually got through it of
course but uh yeah it was not a good 650
days
you spent something like two months in
What's called the Box
I mean can you bear to tell us about
that
uh I can and it was probably the worst
time that that first two months uh where
I was completely isolated from everyone
including the Australian Embassy uh
there was no basis no legal basis and I
was told as to why I was arrested my
captors never identified themselves and
the thing that I called the box was like
the insides of a 20-foot container
shipping container one of those 20-foot
equivalent units that had a concrete
floor and wood veneer paneling walls
nothing in it except for a metal chair
placed in the very center in the room uh
bolted to the concrete floor to which
there were attached lengths of chains
and ankle and uh wrist manacles to which
I would be attached various times during
the interrogation
um and it was that period of course
where I was not allowed any sort of
reading material or anything like that
and so all I had to do was really just
Pace up and down and remember things and
come up with stories and event games
things like that just to you know keep
my mind occupied and keep the Panic at
Bay
what was the embassy doing to get you
out
I was doing a lot of stuff uh in fact
the embassy in Coalition with my wife
and other friends uh put on an
extraordinary amount of activity to try
and get me out it took a long time
ultimately but that was due to the
Myanmar side not not the Australian side
so uh and the embassy was actually very
good at supplying me with food and
ultimately I was able to receive books
and things like that which you know
compensated some of the treatment
earlier uh so yeah they're extremely
active and I know they're in Coalition
with a lot of other governments uh
including that of the UK the United
States Vietnam Singapore and some others
so I think it was a broad International
Coalition that helped secure my release
did you fear at times that you were
losing your mind
uh I didn't really fear that
um I I was more worried I think about
the physical conditions
pretty dire
uh and myanmar's the sort of place where
you don't want to get sick and you
certainly don't want to get sick in a me
and my prison uh so I think I was more
concerned about catching something or
just meeting with an accident uh you
know in facilities that that were you
know not really conducive to to survival
frankly in the long term so I think the
physical things were more important once
the books arrived I was able to I think
you know rally uh mentally uh plus I was
able to be in in touch with my wife at
various times as well and that really
lifted my spirits
how much did you
um regret going to help on San tsuchi
oh I I didn't regret it at all I
regretted being arrested but I I didn't
regret that
um I you know for a long time I've been
associated with uh people in myanmar's
democracy movement and I'm you know
quite committed on that front so so I
didn't regret doing that I certainly
regret what what's happened to Myanmar
and the military takeover and what
subsequently happened uh but you know
what what happened to me of course is
being experienced by thousands of others
uh in Myanmar and of course many worse
things being done to them as well so
um yeah so no no real regrets
um and you know I guess I'm just
motivated now in the hope that something
better will come to myanmar's way before
too long
uh how is she
she's good um she's very strong uh her
conditions are also not very good
um I think the the military dictator
been online has made a number of
comments to the effect that you know
she's in a home-like building I think
was the expression that he used well
that's just completely not true
um she's held in what I'm calling a
little Hut sort of structure uh it has
no facilities Beyond a very simple
bathroom and bed but it doesn't have a
TV it's not air conditioning it doesn't
have
um running water except for some stuff
in the bathroom but it's um it's not a
good facility at all and and she has to
draw on those resources that she's drawn
on for 20 more years to stay to stay
okay but
um yeah but look she's in wonderful
spirits and she's a great help to
everyone else
um I saw her once a week when we were on
trial together and her biggest concern
was to keep our spirits up she was very
concerned for instance at asserting and
helping us in thinking that all in
understanding rather that this court
process was nothing but a share and we
shouldn't take on board any feelings of
guilt and so on we've done nothing wrong
uh and uh that we just needed to be
strong and we have to stand by the truth
and so on uh so yeah so she was not only
strong at Serene as we come to know her
but she was so supportive of other
people who were captives as well
if she were ever to lead Myanmar again
would you go back to work for her
I would work for her outside there but I
think I've I've had my uh my uh Stenton
Myanmar itself I I think I would be
worried about my anxiety Myanmar but I
would certainly work for her I would
have no problem at all on that front
um and just before I let you go tell me
the first thing you did when you uh
landed back home and you knew that you
were safe
I had fish and chips and a glass of red
wine with my wife uh on Sydney Harbor
oh amazing amazing all's well that ends
well it's good of you to take the time
to join us I'm glad you're home safe
thank you
thanks so much Kate thank you